and we do thank you for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis turning to political
news
a local vote recount starts tomorrow for
the clark county district c
seat it was filled by filed rather by
republican candidate stavros anthony two
days after he
narrowly lost to democratic rival ross
miller
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough is
live in the newsroom to share more on
what this means
madison yes on thursday councilman staff
rose anthony
of ward 4 filed for recount of the
district c
commission race after the republican
lost to democrat ross miller by just
10 votes anthony's campaign issued a
statement friday
criticizing the commission's
interpretation of the judge's decision
stating that there are still 139 voters
whose ballots haven't been counted yet
miller narrowly defeated anthony who
would have been the only republican
on the commission if he had won vote
totals in the race were
76 586 for miller
and 76 576 for anthony
joe gloria with the clark county
registrar of voters office
has a speculation stating that since
election day
which was over four weeks ago his office
has received hundreds of calls from
people
who received false information about
their vote not being counted
over 150 000 people voted in this
contest
it's very out of the ordinary for a a
race with that many votes to be decided
by
ten that margin of victory is very
difficult to reconcile no matter what
the race is with 215 precincts in it
now anthony took to twitter earlier on
thursday to announce that he will
ask for a recount and pay for it as
required by nevada state law
if he comes out victorious in the
recount he will be
reimbursed and clark county elections
department staff will begin the recount
tomorrow morning at 5 a.m
the county expects the process to take
five days
and should wrap up by friday december
11. reporting live from the newsroom
madison kimbrough 8 news now